[Music]
the escape of the two characters aniab
and medra those are their true names or
their use names otter and flag from
the complex run by gaelic the evil
wizard who is trying to use both of them
to
find as much mercury or quicksilver as
possible ends the second part of the
story the finder which is the first main
story in ursula k le guin's fifth earth
sea book tales from earthsea and it's a
rather bitter sweet escape it's only
possible
because of the great
magical power of anyab which was not
able to be
shaped and cultivated and taught in part
because the dark world that they're
living in
at the time
you know they talk about
lozen's wizards destroying all the
witches and sorcerers up on the mountain
where anyab is from
and
through anieb and her sacrifice
otter or
medra is able to escape otter is being
used as a finder to
locate the ore of mercury anyab is in a
much worse position she is working in
the
roaster
tower as a roaster and what a roaster is
somebody who is feeding the logs into
the fire and keeping the fire going very
hot so as to take the cinnabar the ore
and get the mercury out of it and the
fumes are slowly killing all of the
slaves as a matter of fact lickey one of
the
people in charge says they only last a
year or two at most
so we first encounter her
in the roaster
chamber they come to the topmost room
gaelic says to the single slave
crouching at the rim of the shaft show
me the king the slave short and thin
hairless with running sores on his hands
and arms uncapped a stone cup
gaelic peered in eager as a child so
tiny so young the tiny prince and he
takes out a pouch of leather and spoons
the quick silver into
his pouch now the slave is being treated
as just a piece of machinery you could
say the slave stood by merciless
motionless all the people who worked in
the heat and fumes of the roaster tower
were naked or wore only breech cloud and
moccasins
otter glanced again at the slave
thinking by his height he was a child
and then saw the small breasts it was a
woman she was bald her joints were
swollen knobs in her bone thin limbs she
looked up once at otter moving her eyes
only she spat into the fire wiped her
sore mouth with her hand and stood
motionless again
and gaelic says yes give your dross to
the fire and it will be purified gaelic
actually tells himself that all these
people are being purified
when really they're just dying of
poisoning and overwork and malnutrition
now she connects with medra
and this is uh quite important
um after you know this this long
discussion
that uh gaelic is is giving
um
they go back to the barracks lickey shut
uh
otter medra as usual into the brick wall
room giving him a loaf of bread and
onion and a jug of
water otter crouched as always in the
uneasy oppression of the spellbound see
he's trapped in a place where spells
surround him and keep him from being
able to use his powers and they even
reduce his cognitive abilities as well
and sometimes make him sick
so
from the turmoil of his mind
something rose coming close coming clear
the image he had seen down in the mind
shadowy yet distinct the slave in the
high vault of the tower that woman with
empty breasts and festered eyes who spat
the spittle that ran from her poisoned
mouth and wiped her mouth and stood
waiting to die she had looked at him now
is this just a memory no
he saw her now more clearly than he had
seen her in the tower he saw her more
clearly than he had ever seen anyone he
saw the thin arms the swollen joints of
elbow and wrist the childish nape of her
neck it was as if she was with him in
the room it was
as if she was in him
as if she was him
she looked at him he saw her look at him
he saw himself through her eyes
so there's something going on here a
connection that is taking place
and then she helped him
he saw the lines of the spells that held
him heavy cords of darkness a tangled
maze of lines all about him there was a
way out of the knot if he turned around
and then so and parted the lines with
his hands so
and he was free he could not see the
woman anymore he was in the alone in the
room standing free so she had sent
herself to him to guide him in the
process of freeing himself of the
sorcerer's snares which are still in in
place
and now freed they can connect in
another way
he's able to realize that gaelic doesn't
actually
understand what he's talking about and
then
he goes back to his old place sat down
on the palate and went on thinking the
prisoning spell was still there yet it
had no power over him now gratitude for
this freedom beat in him as steady as
his heartbeat
he thought about what he must do
and how he must do it he wasn't sure
whether he had summoned her
or she had come of her own will he
didn't know how she had spoken the words
of the old tongue through him when he
discovers what quicksilver really is
he didn't know what he was doing or what
she was doing and he was almost certain
the working of any spell would rouse
gaelic but at last rashly and in dread
he summoned the woman in the stone tower
he brought her into his mind and saw her
as
he had seen her there in that room and
called out to her and she came
her apparitions stood just outside the
spiderweb chords of the spell gazing at
him and seeing him for a soft bluish
sourceless light filled the room
her sore raw lips quivered but she did
not speak
and now he does something that
shows his ultimate trust in in her and
she responds
in kind
he spoke giving her his true name i am
medra
i am anieb she whispered
how can we get free and now notice the
next thing that she says
his name the wizard's name they've just
given each other their own true names if
they can get the wizard who has taken
madras name from him by magic and is
using it to compel him
if they can just get the wizard to
say his own true name then they can have
power over him
and thereby make their escape
and
otter says even if i knew it when i'm
with him i can't speak
and
she says
if i was with you i could use it i can't
call you he says but i can come she says
and that is what she does
she held out and she gives him a signal
she held out her thin hand and a fist
then open it up as if offering him
something then she was
gone
and so now
she can actually
go along with him so to speak for the
ride and act on his behalf and that's
how they end up tricking gaelic there is
a wonderful line there that shows
how she is helping
them out
um
she he says that um
she's like you know the
the lantern that is
helping him see where to go
and so they they take her understanding
is the lamp is the actual
metaphor
she is providing him what he needs in
order to get them through so first anieb
says to gaelic i know where the mother
lode is
i can take you to it
and gaelic says have you found much
better ore than the patch you found at
first it is the load the great load and
then she tells him other things through
otter medra only the master can go there
who is the master well gellick has been
positioning himself as you know the
person who's going to become the
greatest wizard of all perhaps even
greater than wizards dragons will be his
dogs
and it'll all come through the king what
is the king
the principle of the purified
quicksilver which he will become
part of or will become the totality
of so
only the master can go there what master
the master of the house the king and
then anieb says tell him what he sees
meaning make this
metaphorical make this visual to him
and she whispers in honor's mind and he
spoke a stream runs through darkness
over a glittering roof under the roof is
the house of the king the roof stands
high above the floor on high pillars the
floor is red all the pillars are red on
them are shining ruin runes i cannot
read them i cannot go there no one can
enter there in the body but only the
king only he
can read what is written and gaelic you
know this is
telling him exactly what he wants to
hear he's been imbibing mercury and
letting it go through his system
he says welcoming power loving power
rather than fearing it and so he views
himself as as the one person who is
ready for this and they're going to go
to the mother lode now how they trap him
is telling him
that the key
can open the door
only the king has the key
and what is the key
the king's name so now we see gaelic
first trying the name of mercury that
he's given to
otter medra right
taurus which means seed or semen and
that's not the true name of any of that
and then he stops and thinks well i'm
i'm the king
it's my true name and he says it
tinnerel and when he says tynerol and
the
the ground opens up and he can see down
into it and is getting ready to go
to to the hall of this this king
then he is now vulnerable
and anieb shouts in otter's voice tinner
all fall staggering wildly the wizard
tried to run lost his footing on the
edge and plunged down into the darkest
scarlet cloak billowing up the wear
light around him like a falling star and
then otter says close close mother be
healed be whole and the broken ground
groaned and moved drawing together
healing itself the wizard is now
imprisoned under the earth and will die
down there
now they are free
for what though
and here we come to the third part of
this story
they meet up and aneb
madras says anib come with me and she
says i want to go home
he helped her stand their magic is
totally exhausted both of them
still no one paid attention to them as
if a charm of protection was on them
they walked down the stairs out the
tower past the barracks away from the
mines they walked through woodlands
towards the foothills that hid mount on
from the lowlands of sammary
anyab kept a better pace than seemed
possible in a woman so famished and
destroyed walking almost naked in the
chill of the rain all her will was aimed
on walking forward she had nothing else
in her mind not him not anything but she
was there bodily with him and he felt
her presence as keenly and strangely is
when she'd come to the summoning the
rain ran down her naked head and body he
made her stop to put on his shirt
she let him pull it over her head then
walked right on she could not go quickly
but she went steadily her eyes fixed on
the faint cart track they followed till
the night came early under the rain
clouds and they could not see where to
set their feet make the light she said
her voice was a whimper plaintiff can't
you make the light
i don't know he said but he tried to
bring the where light around them and
after a while the ground glimmered
faintly before their feet we should find
shelter and rest otter says
i can't stop she said and started to
walk again he says you can't walk all
night and she says
if i lie down i won't get up i want to
see the mountain the mountain is where
she's from where her family
is and so they walk
all the night until she finally
says look madra look
the pallor of the where light had faded
drowned in a vaster fainter clarity sky
and earth were all one grey but before
them and above them very high over a
drift of cloud the long ridge of the
mountain glimmered red
there any m anab said she pointed at the
mountain and smiled
she looked at her companion then slowly
down at the ground she sank down
kneeling he knelt with her tried to
support her but she slid down in his
arms he tried to keep her head at least
from the mud of the track
her limbs and face twitched her teeth
chattered he held her close against him
trying to warm her and the last thing
that she says is the women the hand
asked them in the village i did see the
mountain
a shuddering seizes her and racks her
she began to gasp for breath
in the red light
that now shone from the crest of the
mountain and all the eastern sky he saw
the foam and spittle run scarlet from
her mouth sometimes she clutched at him
but she did not speak again she fought
her death fought to breathe
and then she dies
and
medra
is there just bawling his eyes out
alongside the road until a carter comes
and picks them both up the dead body of
anieb and medra clinging to her
and takes them all the way to the
village of wood edge
where they meet up with anieb's mother
and
all he could say was she saved me
and she saved me but i couldn't save her
she still wouldn't let her go holding
the rain wet stiffened body against him
as to defend it and that very slowly
they made him understand one of the
women was anim's mother and that he
should give anim to her
to hold he did so at last
watching to see if she was gentle with
his friend and would protect her so
this is nearly the end of the story but
there's more as we find out as so often
through the memorializing
of the dead now
otter or medra didn't get to know anyab
as she was before she was taken
as a slave and they made this escape
it's through the stories that her mother
and her relatives are able to tell him
about her powers and about the things
that she did the kind of person that she
was
um
they they tell her all these different
ways in which she
helped people and then she they say but
she was only a girl like the others too
a good girl
and they tell how she was captured as
well and then they tell them the meaning
of the gesture of the hand
there's two other things that that are
said
in this
one is the despair that otter expresses
he says
in in relation to
to trust
gaelic's gone maybe lozen will fall now
will it make any difference will the
slaves go free
will beggars eat will justice be done i
think there's an evil in us in humankind
trust denies it leaps across it leaps
the chasm but it's there and finally
everything we do finally serves evil
because that's what we are greed and
cruelty i look at the world at the force
and the mountain here and it's all right
as it should be but we aren't
people aren't we're wrong we do wrong no
animal does wrong how could they but we
can and we do
they listened to him not agreeing not
denying but accepting his despair
his words went into their listening
silence and rested there for days and
came back to him
changed
and
there's another thing that that comes up
right before that
he's asking about the secret
and anab's mother says you already know
it you gave it to
her and she gave it to you
trust
this is a very important concept in le
guin's earth sea novels we see this as
an echoing of the trust that is
discussed in tombs of
in
the
tahanu novel as well and so that's a
fitting place to end
this escape where they get to learn
each other and who they are and
anieb helps medra
on his way
you